it's nice to see you
and here we are back in new york city
for an in-person fashion week how
exciting is this i'm so excited i like
the virtual shows but this is way better
to be in real life and yeah here at sac
tonight's a dj so it's gonna be a lot of
fun i know you're gonna be spinning some
tunes for everyone out here that's
exciting i love the throwback post that
you posted tonight on instagram of you
and your sister you've been fixtures
here at fashion week forever we've been
coming since we're little girls
we used to dress as twins everywhere but
now we have our own styles and you guys
look so awesome tonight and i gotta say
it's been a big week obviously for new
york city coming back to life but a big
week for britney spears as well you have
been a huge advocate and supporter for
her i mean we've seen some
overwhelmingly amazing news for her this
week have you spoken to brittany since
the newsroom i haven't spoken about that
yet but i look forward to her having her
freedom she deserves it more than anyone
such a sweet soul and i'm very excited
for her yeah i mean she's one step
closer to you yes one step closer
can you give us any updates on wedding
news with you and mr carter how's the
planet coming along are you talking to
any designer since it is fashion week
and perhaps designing a custom gown for
yourself
yes i'm so excited we've been shooting
my new show with peacock called parents
in love and it's all about that so
a lot of planning going into it picking
up my wedding dress and
it's going to be soon in the next few
months really very soon nailed down the
dress just yet
yes but it's a surprise
i know your mama is over the mood what
do you make of seeing your mama on
the real housewives of season she is a
riot i'm so proud of her it's so fun
just to all my friends calling me about
her
we're together people are coming up and
asking for her picture and like all the
memes like she's
so funny and i'm just happy everyone
gets to see the real hurt
you're like mom this is what nikki and i
are supposed to be doing not use this
i love it i'm so proud of my mom it's so
good well it's nice to chat with you
tonight you look awesome you feel good
you're ready to teach me i'm excited
[Music]